hurray for a dysfunctional accurate
depiction of a family at Christmas is
that something that drew you both to
this series oh absolutely
I mean I think it's something everybody
can relate to you go home for Christmas
and that's not always the best choice I
don't know my family's perfect I was
raised by perfect family and I raised
two perfect children and there's never
been any strife or discord or arguments
at my house ever only on Thanksgiving we
do it all Thanksgiving and then nobody
talked to each other at Christmastime
that's why there's no arguments exactly
nobody gets the other Christmas I have
to ask since this is the Moody's is
there something that makes each of you
Moody over the holidays I know some
people hate shopping what what are you
pointing at me for things Mimi you know
I hate shopping actually I ever told you
to go online or do local only usually
it's local only I will not go do the big
bucks okay but let's be honest with the
people and be honest and like homemade
Christmas ornaments I like gifts that
are wrapped in brown paper with like a
little yarn on the outside she's like a
lunatic she told us and I have several
witnesses some of whom are in this room
right now
she starts shopping up to a year in
advance of Christmas but that's how I
can do it local so you are a Christmas
season on her yeah you told me you these
in the moody house on the set which was
filled with all kinds of Christmas
knickknacks things small things and
nativity scenes but that she does more
than they have in the hello I have an
entire village yeah okay they can entire
village that little houses that light up
we've got people doing things action
figures snow fakes now so is there
something on the set that you actually I
was an entire train that goes around I
do I really do as a Christmas lover is
there something on the set that you've
seen now that you have your eye on that
you're like I already have it off I have
it all their village was like compared
to mine she lectured she lectured us
about Yankee Candles yeah God go to
Yankee Candle for all your Christmas
meanness even online they're an amazing
company they have twinkly trees
Santa going down
it's really good hey you asked you
opened the can of worms where we're
about she's not even getting paid by
these people to say the name of the
company okay
one day she's a Christmas loon I believe
I love Christmas and so does my
character so I fit right in with that
what's that what's the tradition in your
home that is super important to you over
Christmas decorating the Christmas tree
really important I put all of the
ornaments into an antique wooden bowl
and then one by one they have to be hung
on the tree with care she's not making
this up I mean this is kind of like your
character yes completely yes so you
definitely relate to your yes Anna my
middle name is and so and she's great as
an Moody and she's so she's great when
she gets moody as an moody and like when
she loses it and stops around and gets
mad yes drinks them all the kids are
home and well it's just a recipe for
disaster
this is going really well like the
energy of youtube I go to a lot of sets
I know everybody doesn't always you know
get along but this has been fun free
both of you know I hate her I can't
stand ya know it's it's been horrible
it's been one of their worst nightmares
of my profession North Korea no I am of
course I'm joking now we got along yeah
great
we got along fantastic which is my older
older older brother but I was a huge fan
of hers I've never worked with Elizabeth
and I'd never met her I'd always wanted
to work with him so I you know it was
aware of her work and and so that was
exciting and then we got here and like
you know then she told me she's from
Massachusetts and then we started giving
each other cuz I'm from Worcester she's
from we really grew up like around 35
miles yeah basically so there's a lot in
common and I mean I'm not like a pretty
love Christmas but I'm not like this
kind of you know yeah right um so we hit
it off that way and she's got comedy
timing that's just ridiculous
jeez so we played our characters really
well you know trying to find like two
minutes of peace and and in private time
and
house full of construction workers and
grown children one of whom who has not
left and the other two of really yeah
it's you know I don't know what I do I
still had one you shouldn't even talk
about this
you shouldn't even talk about this
because you're asking I'm asking now for
asking you're asking for Mom we broke up
the universe yes and you're on
television saying I am on TV I'm sorry
guys we spoke you kids is gonna watch it
go I'm gonna move back home I miss the
Yankee Candle there anything in the
fridge yeah we spoke to a bunch with the
password for Netflix recently watched by
early what yeah because they have the
password some time never watching the
stupidest shows just sorry we spoke to a
bunch of the children your children in
the show today okay you good protect I
would say are actually my heart almost
and they're coming oh my god oh my god
but they really all have spoke so highly
of both of you as they should as a
shining come on
but as younger actors coming into the
business for them um how important is it
for you to kind of show them how a set
can work because like I said before sets
aren't always let me just tell you
something these three kids are
incredibly talented and we picked up on
that at the read-through and we had a
meeting and we're not teaching these
kids anything because we are hanging on
by our claws to our careers and this
show is about us and so we basically
fought them tooth against a bear shall
we get Chelsea fryer get Francois no
really they're all really a dancer
really and they're good as the
characters yeah and they they have tried
to steal the show from us
yeah they have sometimes it's like
they're not letting we're trying not to
let them steal the show they have their
whole lives ahead of them okay give it
time
come on the show is about
secrets and secrets kind of coming out
everybody has their own secrets is there
a secret that you were able to keep that
eventually came out to your family is
there something that from your past like
I know for me my mother is still alive
this stuff she knows about a lot of
stuff that I did growing up but there's
some stuff I'm sorry I'm not answering
that question yeah no no never no like
that kiss concert in Springfield
yeah about that yeah they will now know
they did all they know smoked a
cigarette
they just know a location that's all
they know is kids they were really drunk
on slow Gin once mm-hmm when I was about
15 up in Warwick Mass up at the top of
the mountain really the hippies live we
tell them the real age
I told them I ate like a bad candy cane
or asymptomatic I told her it was like a
lollipop where does that excuse fly up
all over the living room it is bad did
she buy the candy cake no my mother was
a heavy drinker she is again finally my
fill in this blank for me the Moody's is
going to make your holiday season
terrifying
funny no it's gonna make you laugh your
ass yeah it's really you're gonna laugh
yeah this thing is it's listen it's it's
so relatable because it's really about
the dynamics that happen among siblings
and their parents but for some reason
when the kids are all together they
suddenly become 10 12 14 years old again
even though they're in their late 20s
and that's something I think that most
people can relate to is that sibling
rivalry then it's it's smart and you
know the writing was smart and the
performances by those kids are great
you have two Emmy and Golden Globe
nominated actors in them in the next and
it is really ultimately really really
funny and I think you know every anybody
who doesn't have Christmases like this
you know just hasn't had a real
Christmas
yeah